the jurogan experience do we live in a
weird time man you paying attention all
the stock market [ __ ] with
gamestop so i heard i heard a little bit
about it what it was
we covered we covered it a little bit
yesterday my friend sauger and jetty
from uh
the rising the hill he he covered it and
we played some of his [ __ ]
what basically is going on is these
people
who are uh speculators on wall street
you know they're
they they short stocks meaning they are
gambling that a stock is going to
lose value and so then these redditers
these smart dudes on reddit are like you
know what [ __ ] these people let's just
buy a bunch of this stock and jack that
price up
and so they all got together thousands
of them and they bought a shitload of
that stock and the price went
[ __ ] flying like went way up yeah and
so then all the hedge fund people that
were
gambling on it losing money they lost
billions of dollars
like instantly and wall street started
panicking and so then they realized
these redditors realize they can do this
so they start doing with other stocks
like movie theater stocks and then
and so then this app called robinhood
which is an app which which is
robinhood is supposed to be steal from
the rich give to the poor
that's the story of robin hood instead
they
are protecting all these hedge fund
people by stopping people from doing
this
so they're stopping all the sale of
these stocks that these redditors
all get excited about so these people
even if they buy the stock now they
can't sell it
or now they is that what it is they
can't buy it they can't buy it
they can't buy they can't buy it anymore
they can sell but they can't buy it
so it's they've essentially tried to do
what they can to stop
this scam and everyone is
furious at them so much so that
i sent you an article that uh google
removed over one hundred thousand
one star reviews from their app store
because they they were saving this
application from having one star
in the google app because everyone was
so mad at them but meanwhile that's a
legit
because that's a legit criticism like
here it is
google salvaged robin hood's one star
rating by deleting nearly 100 000
negative reviews
unhappy users have been review bombing
the app
so that's what's going on what basically
has happened in jamar's all these people
forever
have been manipulating the stock market
and making a shitload of money doing it
hedge funds all these billionaire wall
street people now
regular folks on reddit are starting to
do the exact same thing and they're
making
millions of dollars millions of dollars
in the apps
with with stocks and they're trying to
figure out a way to stop these people
from doing this
because they don't want them to be able
to do it they want wall street normal
people or
normal people are being penalized for
figuring out a new way
to hack the system that wall street has
been manipulating forever
i need to tell them is that accurate
what i said does the accurate way
describing it
basically that's a very good simple way
to describe it yeah there's more
levels to it sagar did a much better job
of it
go to uh you can go to his their youtube
page
crystal ball and sauger and jetty it's
called rising
the hill it's my favorite political talk
show because there's a person
saggers on the right and crystals on the
left but they're both
honest and objective and they they
discussed how
how [ __ ] up this is and how crazy it
is it's it's gone on so
after it's still going on today yeah so
after yesterday went on through uh
the stock market because the shutdown
happened i think people's attention was
like well
if they're gonna do that to us let's
take it over the crypto market and so
now the uh dogecoin which started as a
complete joke has like skyrocketed to
not a joke anymore it hit an all-time
high of almost 10 cents yesterday but
it was so minuscule you wouldn't have
understood why you have millions of
shares didn't elon tweet that too so
elon has been adding to this like he'll
tweet something and it'll make something
spike he's like adding
bitcoin to his info i think his bio and
also
that gentleman who's running for
governor of california how do you say i
don't know if he's actually running for
because i saw him get asked that he's
like is this real he was like well
technically you know recall gavin newsom
i don't think he's official he's not
fought paperwork or anything you know
he's having fun
yeah i think so yeah he's having fun but
he tweeted about it too he's in it
did he's a he's an ex he was he was with
google or with facebook
google but did he have anything to do
with facebook ever probably
find out if he did because i i'm reading
um matt taibbi's book um
yes earlier at facebook maybe not google
maybe it was facebook then i'm sorry
instead of google correct
okay but he's basically explaining in
one of his tweets
recently pulled that up because he was
comparing robin hood
to facebook and he's saying that they
pretend that you're a customer
but you're not a customer in fact you're
the client
and they you know what you are is you're
the product
and they pretend that they're doing you
service but what they're really doing is
they're
taking all of your data and they're
selling it and they're getting rich
and they're not giving you any of that
money and that's the same thing with
robin hood
it's the same sort of scenario he he he
laid it out
in his twitter but it's it's a situation
where
once this genie is out of the bottle
where these regular people have
figured out how to manipulate stock
markets and
truth be told i don't know jack [ __ ]
about stock markets i don't know
anything
i literally barely pay attention but
they've figured out how to manipulate it
and once they figured out how to do this
they can keep doing this thing
unless i don't know how they're going to
stop it i have no idea how you're going
to stop reddit
how are you going to stop these
intelligent [ __ ] people with plenty
of time
i mean so they're organizing i mean so
can
like um like like but you'd have to know
how to actually do it because i was over
here like
maybe i should call my maybe i should
call my brother and tell me he should um
yeah get in on this but it's like a
ponzi scheme it's like a pump and dump
right the idea is like you get in early
and then it gets to a certain point you
got to realize like okay
it's time to get out it's time to get
out like if you buy it a dollar and then
it gets to 30
and then you're like [ __ ] this is this
might crash soon get out now
i don't know what the number would be
i'm just saying it i think that's what a
lot of people think but the
understanding
i have of the this gamestop situation is
what makes it a little different is that
short squeeze situation is where
there's contracts which i think it just
happened because the market just closed
because those contracts exist someone
has to buy that contract at the end of
the day when the contract comes to
when does the market close four o'clock
every day oh four o'clock east coast
time i'm just closing a half an hour ago
so that's what this big issue was these
contracts you could tell we're going to
close on the 29th
which is friday at 4 p.m and when that
happens whoever holds that contract
has to fill they have to fill the
contract so they'll find the shares
oh oh so that's what's trying to drive
the price people are [ __ ]
so we'll see what happens after the next
couple days which like after hours
trading it's
not something a retail investor gets to
do and this has funds do get to do
that's what was happening uh maybe two
days ago they were driving the price
down because they have the ability to do
that
they have abilities that retail
investors don't have and that's really
the big argument i feel like is going on
right now it's like they can do [ __ ] we
can't do
it's all it's all so weird because the
stock market has always been this weird
number thing that's based on confidence
like you can decide
buy sell where is it going where is it
going sell it sells households sounds
stressful
oh my god i had a friend of mine that i
uh used to do taekwondo with that became
a stock market guy
and he was just into coke and hookers
and then he got
he got into the stock market and i ran
into him once this is when i was doing
stand-up
i hadn't seen him forever he's like not
a guy that you would think
of being as a a market guy he's a tank
he's like
5 10 220 big thick
[ __ ] neck always partying just a
[ __ ] animal i think he was on
steroids
and i ran into him and he was just doing
coke and drinking
yeah and uh telling me he's in the stock
market now it's like you're you're a
stock
broker he's like bro it's [ __ ] fun
man i [ __ ] love it man
we're selling stocks we're making money
like he was an animal
like that this dude was i i thought of a
stock market
analysis being a guy with like a pocket
protector
like warren buffett or some [ __ ] well
back in the day like i thought they had
a calculator and a computer and they
really knew a lot about the business
and they were just really calculated
about their investments and then i ran
into this wild dude that i knew
from my fighting days i'm like this
guy's wild i'm like you're a stock
broker
and he was like dude that's what we do
how long has they been in it i
mean this is we're talking about a long
time ago i just
ran into him randomly at a comedy club
but he had been doing it for a few years
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience
on spotify you can listen to the jre in
the background while using other apps
and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience